all right so this talk is on dependent
types who knows what dependent types are
or a sort of them awesome cool so you
can all correct me after this talk is
done and as long as you don't start with
well actually we'll be in will be an
awesome shape so I think most of us are
familiar with type systems and the idea
of types and programming languages a
dependent type is a type that depends on
a value so rather than just list of
integers you can have a dependent type
where you say a list of integers where
each entry in that list is strictly
larger than the one before it so you can
have a monotonically increasing sequence
or you can have a pair and say you know
the second value has to be larger than
the first time dependent types have
actually been around in some form for a
long time so back in 1934 Haskell curry
discovered that there are similarities
and in fact a correspondence between the
type of lambda calculus and
propositional logic so if this then that
is therefore that this and that this or
that etc but things got really
interesting in the 1960s when william
howard and i'm gonna pronounce this name
incorrectly but i'm gonna try very hard
nickel lost they're growing extend to
Bravin actually I think is closer
I'll talk to Gerry afterwards extend
curries work to predicate logic and so I
found a very nice graphic on the
Internet
credits appear down at the bottom I tell
you what all this means so let's say we
want to make an array right we have two
types here a PI type on top and a Sigma
type on the bottom and what these are
really boil down to are the Universal
and existential quantifiers so this
first one basically says for all X we
can make this array which is kind of
awesome and the sequin tag responds to
the existential modifier so Universal on
top existential on the bottom
existential meaning they're just an X
there's at least one X such that this is
true and this is actually kind of
astounding because as we see Haskell
curry has worked on this back in 1934
William Howard and and debating have
looked at I worked on this more recently
about 50 60 years ago but curry and how
are their names that we probably know
because of the curry Howard
correspondence the idea that he's
propositional these logical ideas
actually are one-to-one with programs
but this was kind of mind-blowing for me
because I didn't know that dependent
types were part of this and that you can
actually encode all of this in this
notion of universal an existential
quantifier with dependent types and the
language that I know that influence
dependent types the best or at least the
one I'm most familiar with his language
called address which is named after a
cart
dragon anyway so if you're familiar with
Haskell this will look relatively
straightforward if you're not that's
okay I was gonna put in that I don't
have you've seen this on Twitter there's
someone if you can I think a couple
years ago basically had this picture
like they replaced all of the English
letter characters the Latin characters
with hieroglyphics and you still get the
Haskell type signatures but it's like
little birds and rivers and stuff like
that and people found that equally
confusing so I thought that was kind of
interesting that you can kind of
translate them into hieroglyphics and
people are still struggling anyway so
this is a vector so in this case we
basically have a sequence of a defined
length so to help you read this data
vector takes a natural number at a type
and gives you a type and the idea here
is if you have nil you just have the
empty vector of a it doesn't matter what
a is because there's nothing in it
there's a length of zero otherwise you
have an A and a bunch of so X of type a
and more X's which are and the X's are
just a vector of that length of type a
and you get a vector if you add this X
of type A to the existing list of type
A's you get a vector of length n plus
one so the cool thing here is you have a
type that actually tells you how many
items are in your vector now if you look
at the idris language website you go to
drew selling that org slash example they
use Z and s for 0 and successor but the
idea is the same basically if you have a
vector of A's of some like then and you
add one more you now have a vector of
A's that is one larger than the one that
you had before and the fact that the
type system can tell you this I think is
really amazing so let's look at what
this can be used for right so here's an
example this function is called pair add
you can imagine you have two vectors and
you want to add all the elements in them
so if you have one two three and four
five six you might want to say one in
three is four two and five is seven and
three and five is eight if I did that
right probably not four five six sorry
three and six is nine anyway math so
we'll talk about totality in a second
but the idea here is you have numeric a
so this is very similar to Pascal's
notion of type classes these are
actually I think a Juris interfaces but
what you're saying is you have something
that implements numeric where you have a
total wording you have a vector of these
A's you actually am n of them and you
take two vectors of length n of A's and
you get a vector of A's that is also
like that so the type system is actually
telling you and if you add these two
vector
pairwise together you will get another
vector of the same type that is the same
length as the original so parrot and
Neil Neil equals nil this is because you
take the head of the empty list you get
no or nothing in integers and then
otherwise if you take an X and some X's
so the head of the list in the rest of
it and do the same thing for your second
vector you just add those two together
and then you recursively do the same for
the rest of your lists which is actually
again astounding that the type system
can tell us you can tell you this
another good example again we have a
total function and I'll tell you about
totality in a second so append we have a
vector of length n if I use again and
now another vector that is of length M a
phase and the resulting vector is n plus
M so we actually have in the type system
a guarantee that if we take these two
vectors and have them together they will
be the right length so again if we
append nil we just get what we had
before
otherwise we take the head of the list
and the rest of them we take our Y's and
we said we're just going to recursively
go ahead and say we're going to append
our X's to our wise so I think this is
astounding that the type system does all
this for us like I said this is this is
nuts that you actually have this in your
type annotation totality basically the
idea here is that you're telling the
ITER's compiler I want you to yell at me
if I have not covered every possible
input
I want to guarantee that my function is
well defined for all inputs and that it
will eventually terminate now Idris has
ways of handling totality but the nice
thing about saying total here is that
you're gonna get the compiler to yell at
you immediately at compile time if you
don't do this now I have done some work
on interest and it's really tough to
find a lot of practical examples right
people are I think relatively new to
dependent types there's not a lot of
really cool stuff that's being done with
it in production now but I found this
issue on a book about type theory on on
github and the really fascinating thing
here is that we are already doing these
these things and I'm gonna read the
highlighted part real quick in computer
science the dependent types are
everywhere but they are not typically
captured by code programmers think
informally in terms of dependent types
all the time they're just how to where
of it for example something like string
copy is a really a dependent function
because the length of the input string
depends on the size parameter right but
this is not visible in the function
declaration is just part of the docs and
what do we know that if we take
something that the programming language
can do and we push it into the docs it
doesn't get done we find a still comment
and we fight with things and things are
on fire so I really like putting these
things in the programming language
because then I don't have to worry about
it the computer worries about a brief
aside so I mentioned I was doing some
web stuff with hideous years ago I
wanted to contribute to the core
language and I said hello I would like
to use the socket library
socket library is currently broken and
the response was huh okay well if you'd
like to fix it here's how we go about
this and I was confused because you know
things like the socket library being
broken sided pretty critical so I said
how did this get to be like this I feel
like I'm not the first person who's had
this problem the answer was that I was
and so having this conversation the
conversation was very very collegiate
very nice awesome the folks over it are
so delightful
but the undercard this is this might be
in my imagination but the idea here was
sort of the subtext was you know they're
almost like what are you doing with
interest and I said well I would like to
put cat pictures on the Internet
that's what I that's why I program
things so I can put captures I type cat
pictures on the Internet and so they
responded and said that's interesting
and I said well what do you use interest
for and they said well we're using it
for you no proof assistance and formal
verification and I was like well that's
weird like I don't know why you guys are
doing that I don't know why you guys are
doing that so it's really fascinating to
have this programming language that we
were both super delighted to use and
completely different use cases where
each of us not the other person with you
you I guess but so very quickly we're
gonna talk about undecidability in type
language didn't I hear you apologies for
going so fast but I got about a minute
left so undecidable right I'm not sure
that word means what I think it means
but the idea here is the wind types
contain values they can become little
programs and if you have too little
programs and you generally want to know
if those two programs they're going to
do the same thing for all possible
inputs that is actually undecidable
which is super scary luckily like we
talked about totality earlier you can
tell you just yell at you if something
is not total but generally speaking at
compile time is only go to evaluate
things that it knows our total already
which means that type checking remains
decidable and everybody is happy anyway
I've got about 20 seconds left
I'm really happy these are the papers
that I had used to talk about type
theory to learn about things to learn
about the Haskell curry correspondence
and you know we forgot that dependent
types and things like that so feel free
to take a look at these I'm gonna put
these up on speaker deck and show the
link on Twitter a little bit like I said
I'm usually at Eric Q Weinstein he was
in queue in case I talked way too fast
or you got tired TLD PA too long didn't
pay attention dependent types are
amazing Idris is amazing and you should
try it you're amazing thanks so much
it's all about
[Applause]
[Music]